[Music]
SE
na that is such a great short video that
speaks so much to Performance it took me
a moment to realize what he is doing
he's just singing the actual chords
themselves this speaks to the power of
performance that sometimes it doesn't
even matter the words that you're saying
it's based on the way that you are
saying them that has an impact and this
we see all the time in actual public
speaking as well where it's not just the
words it's the body language and the
pair language so body language being how
are you positioned are you speaking in a
confident way and Par language being how
are you sounding what's your pitch
what's your vocal variety Etc so you
want to think about what are you
communicating not just with your words
but also with your body language and Par
language so that maybe you can get a
better message out there or so that you
can sing some chords this is something
that entertainers do very well which is
one of the seven humor personas if you
want to find out exactly what kind of
funny you are then check out the quiz in
the bio